The three laws in genetics form the crux of this topic.
These laws not only answered a few questions,
but were even ahead of time!
They were instrumental in proving a few important
concepts which were discovered in the following
years!
But do all the organisms always follow these
fundamental laws?
When crossed, do all organisms always give
offsprings in the ratios that Mendel obtained?
Not really!
Even this has exceptions!
But before we get to know the exceptions to
these laws, let us first try answering some
interesting questions that will help us understand
the concepts learned so far thoroughly!
To begin with, let us imagine we have this
plant with axial flowers.
We know that the axial flower position trait
is dominant over the recessive trait of the
terminal flower position!
So this plant has the dominant genes for the
character “flower position”!
Now this is the phenotype of the plant, which
is understood by a mere glance at it!
But can you tell me what the genotype of this plant is?
Is it homozygous or heterozygous for this character?
Let me simplify this for you.
Let us consider the alleles “A” in capital
to represent the dominant trait “axial position”
and “a” in lower case for the recessive
trait “terminal position”.
So can you tell me whether this plant has
the genotype “AA” or “Aa”?
Just a glance is not enough.
It could be either!
Now I am going to ask you an interesting question
and I want you to really try your best to
answer it!
Is there any way in which you can find the
genotype here?
Think about it.
Maybe a test would help?
Can we look at the chromosomes and say which
genes are present on them?
Nope, that’s not possible at all!
Then what kind of a testing method will help us?
It’s simple actually!
The only way to know the genotype of this
plant is by crossing this with a plant whose
genotype is known to us!
So what plant will we opt for in order to cross?
The best choice will be a plant that is RECESSIVE
in phenotype.
In this case we will opt for a plant with
terminal flowers!
But why should we take a plant with a recessive trait?
Why not dominant?
Because for a recessive plant, it will definitely
have the alleles “aa”, BOTH in lower case.
This is the genotype we can be sure about.
This is the unknown genotype for us!
After crossing, the F one generation will
get one allele “a” written in lower case
from this parent.
So we write these “a” in all these four places.
Talking about the genotype of our plant, there
could be two possibilities.
One, it could be ‘AA’ both capital.
Or it could be “Aa’ one in capital and
the other in lower case!
These are the two possibilities or cases!
Let us look at case 1.
On crossing, in the F1 generation we obtain
all the plants which have axial flower positions.
This means all the plants will be heterozygous
with one “capital A” and one lower case
“a”.
Now we move on to case 2.
Look at the plants obtained in the F one generation.
We got 2 axial, and 2 terminal.
They are in the ratio ‘one to one’.
What can we deduce from these 2 cases?
Simple…
We can guess the unknown genotype by looking
at the results in the F one generation!
If we cross our plant with a plant having
a recessive phenotype, AND we get all plants
with flowers in axial positions, then the
genotype of our plant will be ‘AA’ both
in capital.
And if we get plants with dominant and recessive
traits in the ratio one to one, then the genotype
of our plant will be ‘Aa’ one in capital
and the other in lower case.
Wasn’t this interesting?
We used another plant to find the genotype of a plant.
This type of a cross is referred to as a “TEST CROSS”.
It is a cross where the individual’s zygosity is found.
Zygosity simply means the homozygous or
heterozygous nature.
It is found by crossing it with a recessive individual.
Test crosses are the most powerful tools used
in several experiments.
Let us try to solve another question in the next part!
Phenotype and genotype are the important concepts
which we know pretty well!
Can you tell me how many phenotypes are obtained
on crossing a homozygous plant having Round
and yellow seeds with another homozygous plant
having wrinkled and green seeds?
We want the NUMBER of phenotypes and not the ratio!
Let us crack this together!
The first thing we need to note is that we
are looking at two characters.
Seed shape and seed colour.
We are crossing this plant with the one having
wrinkled and green seeds.
So isn’t this a Dihybrid cross?
Yes it is!
Now let’s get to the next step!
We are supposed to calculate the number of
phenotypes obtained.
On crossing these, the F1 generation as we
know, will always have all the dominant characters
expressed.
This is because the F1 hybrids are all heterozygous
in nature.
So there’s just one phenotype the F 1 generation
that is ‘round and yellow’ in this case.
What about the number of phenotypes in the
F two generation?
If you remember the table of any dihybrid
cross, we obtain the phenotypic ratio 9 to
3 to 3 to 1.
Take a moment to go through this table that
we’d seen previously!
What will be the number of phenotypes in the
F two generation?
As there are FOUR different varieties of plants,
we can say that there are four phenotypes.
You should know that a Dihybrid cross always
gives us four different phenotypes in the
F2 generation!
Now let us make it more interesting!
Can you tell me what the genotypic ratio obtained
in the F two generation after a Dihybrid cross?
9 to 3 to 3 to 1 is the phenotypic ratio.
You can pause the video and try finding the
genotypic ratio of these offsprings!
The answer is tricky!
The genotypic ratio obtained for the F2
generation is this!
Huge isn’t it?
Why is it so big?
It’s because there are 9 different genotypes
according to the table!
Study of genetics is indeed very interesting!
Now can you answer one more question that
Nora has for you?
She wants to know which cross or crosses explain
the Law of Independent assortment ?
Think about the law first!
It states that, “Genes for different traits
can segregate independently during gamete
formation.”
Now if we consider a monohybrid cross, then
the event of assortment of genes is ruled
out as there is only one pair considered at a time!
However, when there are two or more genes
involved, as we can see in this case, the
dominant and the recessive alleles of the
different genes assort independent of each
other!
That is the reason why we get four different
combinations at the end!
Thus this law is best understood when we study
DIHYBRID or higher crosses which involve MORE
characters.
‘d’ is the best answer!
Well, we have been talking about Dihybrid
crosses and Dihybrid ratios since quite some
time.
Let’s try cracking just one simple question
related to a Trihybrid cross in the next part!
We have been talking about Monohybrid and
Dihybrid crosses for quite a while.
Now let us try answering a question related
to a Trihybrid cross!
It’s very simple!
Let’s say, we consider the three characters
like the height of the plant, seed shape and
seed colour, all being genotypically heterozygous!
Now can you guess how many possibilities or
combinations of gametes will be formed from
these?
Will there be four possibilities, or six,
or eight combinations?
You can pause the video and make the necessary
calculations on a paper!
We get eight possibilities when a heterozygous
individual for all the three traits is considered.
The simple trick is by using the formula 2 raised to n.
Here, “n” is the number of characters
considered at a time.
Now since this is a Trihybrid cross, the formula
will be 2 to the power 3, which gives us 8!
So there are 8 possible combinations of gametes
that are obtained.
Now to take it a step ahead, can you tell
me the different combinations of genes in
these eight gametes?
Let’s solve this together!
The genotype of this parent is “TtRrYy”
all letters written in one upper and one lower
case to represent heterozygous genotype.
To get the gametes, we take the help of the
Law of independent assortment.
According to the law, the alleles for different
genes will assort independent of each other.
So in simple words, the alleles “T” and
“t” will assort independent of the other
alleles “R” and “r” and even “Y” and “y”.
That means this “T” can get assorted with
either “R” or “r” and similarly with
either “Y” or “y”.
There’s a simple way to find the combinations!
We write the letters “capital T” and “lower
case t” four times each.
Why do we write it four times?
That is because we know that each allele has
the possibility of assorting with all the
remaining four alleles.
So we write the letters “T” and “t” like this!
Now the second set of genes can be assorted
in an alternate fashion written twice.
So we write capital “R” here and here,
followed by “r” in lower case twice.
We repeat the same procedure with the “t”
allele written in lower case.
Now comes the last allele set!
Any idea how will this be assorted?
Well, it’s quite simple!
The last set will be written in single alternate fashion.
That is “Y” in capital followed by “y” in lower case!
This is done one after the other to find all the gametes.
So a total of 8 gametes, or combinations to
be precise, are obtained in an individual
that is heterozygous for all the three traits!
Now let me ask you an extremely interesting question!
If we cross a plant having red flowers with
a plant having white coloured flowers, then
is there a possibility to obtain an intermediate
flower colour like pink?
At the first instance you may say NO!
Most of us would think that the plants in
the F1 generation can either be red or white
depending upon the dominant trait!
But what if I tell you that there are certain
exceptional plants which show this interesting
characteristic?
Want to know about these exceptions?
For that, we will have to understand the exceptions
to Mendelian inheritance!
Meet you in the next part